self-described racial Justice Advocate
named Ali Henny as a racial Justice
Advocate I'm often invited to give talks
or to do workshops where I talk to white
people about race a big part of my
practice is to offer real life stories
examples that type of thing that help
white people to be able to identify
white supremacy in everyday life my
husband's family is white and I often
use the cultural differences between my
family and his family as a way to help
white people see their whiteness there's
one example that I use that always gets
a ton of push back my husband and I were
late to our first Thanksgiving with his
family I say late because it started at
12 we got there at 12:10 but whenever we
got there at 12:10 everybody was already
sat down and eating I didn't know that I
Ed this illustration to point out that
different cultures have different
understandings of time lateness and what
it means to be polite oh she didn't know
that she didn't know that if something
starts at 12 and you get there 10
minutes after the thing starts you're
late